Court delivered its judgment on the Lord
advocate's reference seeking Clarity on
whether or not the Scotland act 1998
allows the Scottish Parliament to
legislate for a referendum on
Independence
first of all while I am obviously very
disappointed by it I do respect and
accept the Judgment of the court in
securing Scotland's Independence we will
always be guided by a commitment to
democracy and respect for the rule of
law that is a principle an important
principle but of course it also reflects
a practical reality The Roots we take
must be lawful and Democratic for
Independence to be achieved and as is
becoming clearer by the day achieving
Independence is not now just desirable
it is essential if Scotland is to escape
the disaster of brexit the damage of
policies imposed by governments we do
not vote for and the low growth High
inequality economic model that is
holding us back
however we must be clear today that the
Supreme Court does not make the law it
interprets and applies the law if the
Devolution settlement in the Scotland
Act is inconsistent with any reasonable
notion of Scottish democracy as now
seems to be the case that is the fault
of Westminster lawmakers not the
justices of the Supreme Court
in addressing the implications of
today's ruling it's also important to be
mindful of what the court was not asked
to decide and therefore what the ruling
does not tell us the court was not asked
to decide if there is a democratic
mandate for a referendum the Mandate and
the Parliamentary majority for the
referendum is quite simply undeniable
nor was the court ask if Scotland should
be independent only the Scottish people
can be the judge of that and it was not
asked if there is any Democratic means
by which Scotland can choose
Independence the question the court was
asked to decide indeed the only question
the court could reasonably answer was a
narrower one would a bill providing for
an advisory referendum or Independence
be within the current powers of the
Scottish parliament in other words can
the Scottish Parliament legislate for an
independence referendum without the
prior agreement of Westminster now as we
know the court has answered that
question in the negative
it has determined that under the
Scotland act 1998 which of course
encapsulates the current Devolution
settlement even an advisory referendum
asking the question should Scotland be
an independent country is a matter
reserved to the Westminster Parliament
what that means is that without an
agreement between the Scottish and UK
governments for either a section 30
order or a UK Act of parliament to
change its powers the Scottish
Parliament cannot legislate for the
referendum that the people of Scotland
have instructed it to deliver that is a
hard pill for any supporter of
Independence and surely indeed for any
supporter of democracy to swallow
however as I said back in June when I
informed Parliament that the Lord
Advocate had agreed to make this
reference it was always the case that in
the absence of an agreement with the UK
government the question of the Scottish
parliament's competence in relation to a
referendum would end up in the Supreme
Court if not before legislation then
certainly after any decision by
Parliament to pass a bill
so while it is I think a statement of
the obvious that this is not the outcome
I hoped for it does give us clarity
and having that Clarity sooner rather
than later allows us now to plan A Way
Forward however imperfect that might be
now I am enough of a realist to know
that the immediate questions posed by
today's judgment will be for me and the
SNP that is entirely understandable I'm
also long enough in the political tooth
to expect some triumphalism on the part
of unionist politicians
however unionists of a more thoughtful
disposition and yes I do believe they
exist uh well I suspect know that to be
misguided indeed they will have been
hoping that the court as the UK
government asked it to do would have
declined to answer the substantive
question today that's because they will
understand that this judgment raises
profound and deeply uncomfortable
questions about the basis and the future
of the United Kingdom
until now it has been understood and
accepted by opponents of Independence as
well as by its supporters that the UK is
a voluntary Partnership of Nations
the Royal Commission on Scottish Affairs
back in 1950 said this Scotland is a
nation and voluntarily entered into the
Union as a partner
that sentiment was echoed nearly 60
years later by the kelman commission
which described the UK as a voluntary
Union and partnership and it was
reinforced in 2014 by the Smith
commission which made clear that nothing
in its report prevented Scotland
becoming an independent country should
the people of Scotland so choose
for today's ruling tells us however is
that the Scotland act does not in fact
uphold that long-hailed understanding of
the basis of the relationships that
constitute the UK on the contrary it
shatters that understanding completely
let's be absolutely blunt a so-called
partnership in which one partner is
denied the right to choose a different
future or even to ask itself the
question cannot be described in any way
as voluntary or even a partnership at
all so this ruling confirms that the
notion of the UK as a voluntary
Partnership of Nations if it ever was a
reality is no longer a reality and that
exposes a situation that is quite simply
unsustainable I don't often as all of
you know quote former Tory Prime
Ministers but I will make an exception
today in the words of former Tory prime
minister John Major no Nation can be
held irrevocably in a Union against its
will
indeed perhaps what today's judgment
confirms more than anything else is that
the only guarantee for Scotland of
equality within the British family of
Nations is through Independence that
fact is now clearer than ever before
the immediate question of course is what
happens now obviously I'm making these
remarks just a couple of hours after the
court issued its judgment well the terms
and import of the ruling are clear it
will still be important to absorb and
consider the full written judgment
properly I think it's safe to predict
that this will not be my last words on
the matter however my initial views
building on what I said in June are as
Falls
first of all it is worth repeating that
the court judgment relates to one
possible route to Scotland making a
choice on Independence a referendum bill
in the Scottish Parliament without
Westminster agreement
while it is absolutely the case if the
UK was a voluntary partnership that this
would not be needed it does remain open
to the UK government however belatedly
to accept democracy and reach agreement
I made clear again today therefore that
I stand ready at any time to reach
agreement with the Prime Minister on an
adjustment to the Devolution settlement
that enables a lawful Democratic
referendum to take place a process that
respects the rights of people in
Scotland to choose our future in line
with the clear Mandate of the Scottish
Parliament lets politicians make the
case for and against Independence and
crucially allows the Scottish people to
decide
what I will not do however is go cap in
hand
my expectation in the short term at
least is that the UK government will
maintain its position of outright
democracy denial
that position is in my view not just
unsustainable it is also utterly
self-defeating the more content the
Westminster establishment shows for
Scottish democracy the more certain it
is that Scotland will vote Yes when the
choice does come to be made
as for that choice
and for the avoidance of any doubt I
believe today just as I did yesterday
that a referendum is the best way to
determine the issue of Independence the
fact is the SNP is not abandoning the
referendum route Westminster is blocking
it
and in that scenario unless we give up
on democracy and again for the avoidance
of any doubt I for one am simply not
prepared to do that we must and we will
find another Democratic lawful and
constitutional means by which the
Scottish people can express their will
in my view that can only be an election
the next national election scheduled for
Scotland is of course the UK general
election making that both the first and
the most obvious opportunity to seek
what I described back in June as a de
facto referendum as with any proposition
in any party Manifesto in any election
it is of course up to the people how
they respond
no party can dictate the basis on which
people cast their votes but a party can
be indeed should be crystal clear about
the purpose for which it is seeking
popular support in this case for the SNP
that will be to establish just as in a
referendum majority support in Scotland
for Independence so that we can then
achieve independence
that then is the principle however now
that the Supreme Court's ruling is known
and a de facto referendum is no longer
hypothetical it is necessary to agree
the precise detail of the proposition we
intend to put before the country for
example the form or Manifesto will take
the question we will pause how we will
seek to build support above and beyond
the SNP and what steps we will take to
achieve independence if we win now as
you would expect I have views on all of
that however given the magnitude of
these decisions for the SNP the process
of reaching them is one that the party
as a whole must be fully and actively
involved in I can therefore confirm that
I will be asking our national executive
committee to convene a special Party
Conference in the new year to discuss
and agree the detail of a proposed de
facto referendum in the meantime the SMP
will launch and mobilize a major
campaign in defense of Scottish
democracy for we should be in no doubt
as of today democracy is what is at
stake this is no longer just about
whether or not Scotland becomes
independent vital though that decision
is it is now more fundamental it is now
about whether or not we even have the
basic Democratic right to choose our own
future indeed from today the
independence movement is as much of a
democracy as it is about independence
now to conclude before I take questions
of course I am well aware that there
will be a real sense of frustration and
disappointment today in both the SNP and
The Wider movement I share that
my message though is this
well that is understandable it must be
short-lived and I believe it will be
indeed I suspect we will start to see
just how short-lived and the strength of
the Gatherings planned for later today
in Edinburgh and other parts of Scotland
the fact is we have work to do the case
for Scotland becoming independent is
more compelling and urgent than ever
Independence is NOW essential because of
what Westminster control means on a
day-to-day basis for people in this
country now and for future Generations
thanks to Westminster control the UK
economy is in crisis and we're entering
a new age of Tory austerity low-income
households in the UK are now 20 poorer
than their counterparts in France 21
poorer than in Germany let me put that
into context that means the living
standards of the lowest income
households in the UK including Scotland
at 3 800 pounds lower than the French
equivalents thanks to Westminster
control we are subject to an immigration
and Asylum system that neither Works in
practice nor serves our need to grow our
population it mistreats those who come
to our Shores looking for Sanctuary from
oppression and deprives US of the
talents and the taxis of those who want
to live work and contribute to our
country thanks to Westminster control
even The Limited measure of
self-government that Devolution provides
is no longer guaranteed instead the
erosion of the powers of our Parliament
the undermining of the Soul convention
the imposition of the UK internal Market
act and now the retained EU law bill and
if we stick with Westminster control we
are stuck outside the European Union
permanently and that comes at a heavy
cost according to the office for Budget
responsibility brexit will mean in the
long run a fall in national income of
four percent compared with EU membership
equivalent to a cut in public revenues
in Scotland of 3.2 billion pounds all
the main Westminster parties now support
a brexit that Scotland did not vote for
and the brexit conspiracy of Silence
that exists between them means the UK
economy will become weaker and people
will pay a heavier and heavier price
that price will be paid in hard economic
terms but also in the narrowing Horizons
and lots of opportunities for
generations to come
Scotland can do better than this the
example of independent countries across
Europe and the world many with nowhere
near the assets and strengths we have
tells us that loudly and clearly we hear
from Westminster that what is needed is
stability but let's be clear the
Westminster system has shown that it is
not capable of securing stability the
people relying on food banks are not
being offered stability those across our
country afraid to switch on their
heating are not being offered stability
the businesses struggling with brexit
are not being given stability
the young people denied the rights and
opportunities of EU membership are not
being offered stability a UK model that
delivers low growth and low productivity
coupled with sky-high rates of poverty
and inequality does not and never will
offer stability Scotland can do so much
better so yes of course this judgment is
a disappointment but it is not one we
can or will wallow in indeed's getting
the Judgment now rather than later gives
us the clarity we need to plot a
definite Way Forward
fundamentally our job in the
independence movement today is the same
as it was yesterday it is to persuade
persuade a majority of the Scottish
people of the fact that Independence is
the best future for Scotland and ensure
a democratic process that allows
majority support to be established
Beyond doubt
that job is not easy I know on some days
like today perhaps it feels more
difficult than ever but nothing
absolutely nothing worth doing is ever
easy
there is no doubt whatsoever in my mind
the independence will be worth it in my
resolve to achieve independence is as
strong as it has ever been indeed it is
if anything today even stronger
Prosperity equality
internationalism and now without any
doubt the very democracy of our nation
depends on Independence